[Musique]
personne n'aime se faire poser un lapin
les restaurateurs n'ont plus si vous
réservez une table mais que vous ne vous
présentez pas ça peut leur faire perdre
les revenus on peut les comprendre
d'être en colère certaines applications
de réservation ont prévu le coup elle
vous demande votre numéro de carte de
crédit et vous informe que le resto
pourrait vous imposer des frais des
frais qui s'appliqueront si vous lui
faites faux bond voilà qui n'est pas
bête mais minute mon lapin c'est illégal
selon la loi un commerçant peut vous
réclamer des dommages mais seulement
lorsqu'il a une perte réelle qu'il peut
chiffrer en demandant des frais parce
que vous ne vous êtes pas présenté c'est
comme si par magie le restaurateur
pouvait deviner combien il allait perdre
à cause de vous
conclusion soyez aux aguets avec les
applis qui demandent un numéro de carte
si on vous parle de frais vous pouvez
choisir de détaler vers un autre resto
passer le mot
[Musique]